but now how low will they go that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
just how far will the left actually go
to protect their pet causes and their
destructive agenda well we've already
seen that to save their fantasy of a
borderless Nation they'll look the other
way as an endless stream of indigence of
Narcotics and crime wreaks havoc on
Middle America
the White House just isn't interested at
all in the problem at the border they're
actively rooting for the illegals the
more the better in fact especially if
they end up moving into communities
where Republicans have been making
political inroads now today Biden was
just 100 miles or so from the Arizona
border but he's too much of a coward to
travel there to face the reality of what
his administration has done
why why go to a border state and not
visit the Border because they're more
important than going on they're going to
invest billions of dollars in a new
Enterprise
well more important than the sovereignty
of your nation sure now the Democrats
have sunk just as low in the pursuit of
a carbon-free control heavy World
efforts to [ __ ] the fossil fuel
industry have driven fossil few profits
up in the short term at least while
leaving America vulnerable in the
position of a beggar to the world's
dictators
China's just laughing at us as we
unilaterally disarm in the world of
energy and again
Democrats just don't care
the Americans hurt by high prices for
food fuel pretty much everything future
Generations left holding the bag because
of all of this runaway Green Spending
and the entire world hurt by our funding
this proxy war against Russia and that
tops it all off
all of this is happening and the
Democrats don't care what is the grand
home plan to increase oil production in
America
that is hilarious wood that I had the
magic wand on this were in a transition
and transitions are come complicated we
need to manage this transition in a
smart way
tell us Pete now you can write a better
plan to collapse America if you tried
and they're taking a Scorch to Earth
approach on the trans agenda as well
as we know the destruction of the
nuclear family is one of their Premier
agenda items
do you think States should have a right
to ban gender affirming health care I
don't think any state or anybody should
have the right to do that
as a moral question as a legal question
I just think it's wrong as a
pediatrician when it comes to making
sure kids are healthy and happy I know
how important care that affirmed
someone's true identity can be
transgender youth I should be allowed to
to be to be able to go to school freely
to be able to express themselves freely
well in one Northern Virginia suburb a
trans youth expressing himself well went
beyond using the restroom of the
opposite sex
it meant committing a heinous crime
that radical gender and racial activists
have so co-opted the Democrat Party as
school administrators in Loudoun County
Virginia literally covered up a sexual
assault
now you probably recall some of the
details of how that school district
there tried to bury the story of a rape
of a female student
they moved her assailant to another
school without parents knowledge and
then when the victim's father expressed
his understandable outrage at a school
board meeting
they turned him into the villain
well now the grand jury convened in the
matter just released a report detailing
what the school administrators did to
sweep things under the drug
and it's much worse than we thought
according to the report a teacher's aide
walked into the bathroom and despite
seeing two pairs of feet under the stall
door this is during the rape itself
that teacher did nothing
and apparently alerted no one
the report also found that the district
concealed the nature of the attack even
as it was preparing to release a
controversial new transgender bathroom
policy
after the rape the student was
transferred to another school where he
committed other egregious acts of
misconduct against girls that were known
to officials but kept from the public
now even the rapist's own grandmother
told officials that he was a sociopath
but little was done predictably the
student rapist remember at the time he
supposedly was wearing a skirt went on
to commit another sexual assault this
time in a classroom
now when he learned of the anal rape of
His Daughter by a boy again in trans
dress up Scott Smith the father of the
victim rushed to the school but was
initially blocked from entering we
eventually gained access but was
escorted out of the building
the principal contacted the
superintendent's office about getting a
no trespassing letter against the
victim's father
the grand jury reveals that while all
this was happening the rapists remained
missing and at Large
get your mind wrapped around this for a
second the school was more concerned
about containing an Angry Dad than
finding a rapist on the loose
listen
we have to understand that the left has
changed
we kind of used to believe in the 80s
maybe 70s that they were relativists who
didn't believe in absolute truths
but now we Face an aggressive moralizing
left that will pursue its goals whatever
the cost to Americans
and they're going to do this with the
help and they're doing it with the help
of a Consortium of big business teachers
unions woke bureaucrats Hollywood and a
supportive media
they're convinced that you're the
problem you're the ones that need to be
punished
people like this
parents School Personnel are required to
rubber stamp your child's transgender
identity at school without your
knowledge or consent my oldest child
will be starting middle school in the
fall where is her protection if a
biological male is staring at her as she
changes her clothes in the Dr and I lock
your room focus on raising our Rock
Bottom test scores and do away with
exposing minors to sexually explicit
material where is the math where is the
reading where is the history where are
the strong values
strong values well the left's enforcers
certainly have them
but those values are diametrically and
at times demonically opposed to what
most families want for their children
and for the country
for years the left was emboldened to
inflict this Twisted agenda on our
children frankly because parents and
politicians were pretty much asleep at
the wheel
but the good news is
we're waking up
and in Loudoun County Brave parents were
not afraid they stood up and they spoke
up even as they were compared as they
were compared to domestic terrorists by
the doj
if those parents hadn't had the guts to
get involved none of these disturbing
facts would have come to light
and that young female student would have
been in a sense victimized all over
again
so so much for the Democrats and girl
power
the sooner Americans realize how hostile
the left has become to normal American
Life the sooner we can begin to win the
type of political victories that we need
to stop this agenda and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else